Oh
one of the things that I know from when
it you lose a child people come and they
don't mean any harm to surround you with
love and cards and comfort but it was a
period for me where I kind of needed to
be my myself for a while to really
realize and get to adjust that my son is
not going to be here anymore
what do I do sometimes we don't have to
say anything we can hug a person and I
believe as we hug our hearts will
connect and my word stirrers on here for
you morning noon or night I'm praying
for you I'm praying that God would
conference you and strengthen you and to
give you joy in the midst of your sorrow
justice means to me
it's where African Americans brown life
is valued to save as other nationalities
life are valued currently we are not
valued that way and it is so evident
this last month alone there's been five
or four unarmed african-american young
men killed by the hands of those who are
hired and paid to protect and serve us
if we really begin to educate on it and
talk about it we do not talk about it
enough because we don't talk about race
issues enough we need to be able to talk
about them and have those conversations
and educate our generation that all
lives matter and if I cut you or you cut
me we believe the same red blood it's no
difference your life should be just as
valuable as my life and my life should
be just as valuable as your life
we need more African American jurors to
be part of the jury pool we need more
African American and brown Americans to
participate in our voting system and
really work to get some of these law
change that we currently have
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook